well it's that time of year again when  heating costs go up but for many  families around the valley it's a luxury  they can't afford the good news is help  is out there so many great organizations  have resources this morning hope link of  southern nevada is one of them 98  percent of their clients are low to very  low income the organization says utility  assistance is the second most important  assistance they provide  the more we can get this message out of  all these resources available  the less likely i hope that there would  be fewer incidents of uh you know  dangerous situations or fires  you know the space heaters there's so  many warnings on space heaters that  people just don't adhere to  you know or they'll try to build a fire  in the home maybe in a little container  all right people can always visit  link2hope.org or they can call the  number right there on your screen  702-566-0576 and ask for the intake  specialist